[Rires]
[Musique]
j'ai peur de ce que tu vas devenir
parce que je sais ce que c'est d'avoir
mal je pourrais pas t'empêcher d'avoir
mal
tu sais je veux que tu sois heureuse et
je veux te voir tomber amoureuse et même
si je vais te protéger
parfois je vais te voir te voir tomber
et si les filles
de sommes fragiles
sache que dans toi une force qui se
déploie quand toutes les filles ce sera
pas facile
mais moi je crois en toi
je vais te confier mon plus gros secret
j'ai toujours eu un peu de malade et je
rentre tous les jours à devenir douce je
crois que j'ai fait le tour j'attends
que ça pousse je te confier mon plus
gros secret j'ai toujours un peu de mal
à m'aimer maintenant ce que j'espère que
tout mon coeur c'est toi tu feras pas le
même erreur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
du moment et c'est la chanson préférée
de Magali la coiffeuse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
je veux que tu sois heureuse
et je veux te voir tomber amoureuse et
même si je veux te protéger
parfois je peux voir te voir tomber
et si les filles
de son fragile
sache que ta
force qui se déploie comme toutes les
filles ce sera pas facile
mais moi je crois en toi
[Musique]
doudou
j'attends toujours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous la connaissez tous c'est parti je
la fais avec ma gaine
[Rires]
[Musique]
sur les parking
de blues
[Musique]
les récentes qu'on aimait trop les Grecs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les gars
[Applaudissements]
chanter sur la tête de ma mère
[Musique]
dans les hôtels sur les parkings
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tes coups de blues des coups de fil tout
recommencera au printemps
[Musique]
les rêves s'entassent dans les métros
les gratte-ciel nous regarde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis pas bien dans ma tête
j'ai perdu le goût de la fête maman
[Musique]
regarde comme ta fille est faite
je trouve pas de son sabbat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mettez-moi l'autre
[Musique]
je suis pas prête
[Applaudissements]
je suis pas prêt quand tu vois grandir
en fait Renault pour échanger toutes les
chansons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]